kourtney kardashian and scott disick may
not be a couple anymore
but court was right by scott's side for
his lavish 38th birthday bash
i'm just like living life and whatever
happens
happens on monday lord disick threw an
over-the-top birthday bash with an
aviation theme
in true kardashian jenner style the
party featured a large balloon display
reading happy birthday lord there was
also a churro truck
if you know you know so good you guys
which kim kardashian documented in
detail on insta
okay if you know me you know i'm
obsessed with churros and i will break
any diet
and court she was into it too posting
this snap of the sugary treat to her
insta story i love it the 42 year old
pooch founder who shares three kiddos
with
scott also shared this brief moment at
her ex's birthday party with singer sia
keep going looks like a fun little
soiree right
you guys want to know what scott has for
his party favors
that's what i want to show you guys i've
never heard of this before party favors
like this
yeah trust me no one has seen party
favors like this before
these are scott's party favors you guys
nice little rolly
so anyone can just walk in here if
they're invited to the party
whatever you want that they get
the lord does it i'm sorry that
everybody else gives out candy
i give out ice diamond covered
rolex watches and jewelry it was a lot
of fun
but scott wasn't just giving out the
goods he was receiving them too
his girlfriend amelia gray hamlin gifted
him with a brand new harley-davidson
motorcycle
which he shared to instagram writing new
harley can't complain
along with a big old thanks to his gal
pal
the 19 year old model also shared this
week clip
cozying up to her man alongside the
caption birthday cutie
the couple has been together since last
november but things have started to get
more serious between them recently and a
source told et
that scott is amelia's first serious
boyfriend
quote amelia and scott are doing well
amelia is mature for her age and scott
and her get along great and things
are easy as for court things have been
heating up between her and boyfriend
travis barker since they first got
together back in january
the couple has packed on the pda
vacation together and he got her name
tattooed on his chest
yeah the keeping up with the kardashians
star even gave the blink 182 drummer
some ink herself
writing i love you a source told e.t
earlier this month
getting engaged and married one day has
definitely been a topic of conversation
between courtney and travis
travis would absolutely love to tie the
knot with courtney but courtney hasn't
been sure that's the step she wants to
take in their relationship right now
she is extraordinarily happy and doesn't
feel the need or want the pressure of
getting married
with courtney and scott both content in
their respective relationships
seems like they've really got a handle
on the whole friendly exes who co-parent
thing
a topic scott and court sister chloe
opened up to et about in 2019.
i think they're doing amazing and i
think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but i'm so proud of
them it's a beautiful thing to get along
with each other and for your kids to see
[Music]
that